I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense I feel like and this will kind
of play into the guys and and also me
like I mean I there's times where I want
to gain more muscle so what do you have
to do to gain muscle yeah is that what
happens is that what happens as time
goes on with most people as they've kind
of like lost that sort of I don't know
if it's age or like the hormones that
reduce your muscle mass but essentially
you just kind of you're like oh it's
just getting old getting fat and is it
because of our reduction in lean muscle
mass it's really interesting a lot of
people think of getting older means that
uses muscle mass it's not Frank what's
happening is as you get older people
tend to move right right not baling hay
anymore no not picking girls up come on
scoop us up basic you want to build
muscle and people hear that you're like
build muscle
I know it's like the way that I think
this is not lifting heavy weights for be
really looking like Arnold
Schwarzenegger is like so many bad ones
yeah I know
you're right you're so right got it you
know yeah but there's yeah oh yeah with
blades next to their face blades of
glory
so I can think about who the Iron Cross
hunger okay okay well what makes you
strong I'm um I see bulky more generally
fewer urs heavier weight okay if you're
doing higher up yeah that you want to
look heavier weight for Europe if you
like by up to ten reps
it is good range restrict that's the
hypertrophy sort of zone right okay so
that's key so if you're if you are in a
caloric deficit we're gonna be
maintenance floor deficit you're on your
spot and you're true and you're and
you're lifting weights to gain muscle
you won't will you get stronger yeah
okay you can get stronger but you cannot
gain so it's about recruiting more of
the muscle at the same time Wow how do
you do that that is $59.99 per month
the rules again property right we right
okay okay yeah yeah just exactly good
father yet yeah more courts well this
isn't a math program back it down yeah
thank you there you go that's better for
me
you